Yeah,
I mean,
I think,
you know,
Kubler Ross did a,
an enormous service to medicine and to,
you know,
to the world at large by drawing
attention to the importance of,
of basically,
um,
reactions to dying and then to death
itself.
However,
her insights or whatever her,
her ideas,
I think about what exactly happens,
have not turned out to be very helpful
because they don't turn out to be very
accurate.
Um,
and so what,
what I think about,
um,
the trajectory of grief really is
informed very much so by many colleagues
who have now done work looking closely
at that,
um,
process in different kinds of
situations.
And I think that I put it together in a
slightly different way than,
than maybe some other people do.
But,
but I think that,
um,
what actually happens when someone dies
that you're,
again,
that you're very close to.
That's what really what we're talking
about here.
Because,
um,
you don't go through such a dramatic
process when it's someone that,
you know,
but so this is someone very,
very close.
So what happens,
um,
how I understand what happens is that we
have to start with what is that love
relationship to start with.
And the,
you know,
love is something that we all feel and
that we're,
we're biologically probably programmed
to feel.
And in,
in psychology or psychiatry,
we talk about a love relationship as an
attachment relationship.
And so the attachment system is a
biological system that actually curves
and other animals,
not only in humans and it,
it begins even before we're born.
So baby can recognize its mother on the
very first day of its life.
And then of course,
you know,
you get that very strong attachment
relationship between an infant and it's
caregiver.
Usually it's mother and other people in
it's environment.
And then as the child grows,
grows older,
there may be a couple of other people
too,
which it's very,
very attached.
And,
and actually what starts to happen also
as a child gets older is that the child
starts to learn how to be a caregiver
because of course the mother is the
caregiver early on.
So,
so as we get older,
and by the time we're adults,
we are caregivers for the people that we
take care of us.
So what happens when someone dies is
that we lose not only the person who's
taking care of us,
but also the person who,
a person who we put a lot of energy and
a lot of ourselves into taking care of.
And actually it turns out that for
adults,
if you make them decide,
is it more important,
you know,
if you make them choose,
is it more important to take care of
someone else or to be taking care of
yourself?
Do you have any idea what they'd say?
So basically they,
they will always say,
most of the time say that it's much more
important to feel good about taking care
of someone else.
So now,
you know,
now let's go back to the bereavement
situation because what's happened is
someone has died who's very important to
you to being a sort of,
it's the person who,
um,
you turn to when you're under stress or
the person who's kind of behind you,
cheering for you when you're,
when you're trying something new or
having confidence in you when you're
doing something.
And that's very important,
but you're,
but this is also the person that you do
those things for and that you try to
protect and help in their life.
So when they die,
by definition,
you failed as a caregiver.
So one of the things,
so basically the two things that happen
when someone dies is that attachment
system gets very activated.
And so does the caregiver system.
And what does that mean in everyday
life?
Would that means that you start to
think,
how am I going to manage without this
person?
And then you also think,
why didn't I prevent this death?
I could have done,
you know,
I should have done something to make it
better.
I should have,
you know,
take the World Trade Center.
A lot of people had the thought,
why didn't I stop this person from going
to work that day?
You know,
even though it was not rational thought,
these are not rational thoughts.
Of course you're going to manage without
this person.
Of course you didn't,
you know,
do something to lead to this person's
death.
But they're automatic instinctive
thoughts.
So that's the first thing that happens.
And so you start to have these different
kinds of problems to solve and that's
really acute grief.
That's what you start to think about.
And you start to think a lot about,
you know,
you try to find the person for both
reasons in your mind because we have,
um,
we have,
we think a very special place in our
minds for the person who we're so
attached to.
And so what we have to do is we have to
gradually come to terms with the fact
that that person is gone forever and
that information is very difficult.
Okay?
Very difficult to accept.
And so we don't accept it right away.
In the beginning,
we,
we feel a sense of disbelief.
And we also,
um,
have that,
you know,
people will,
will feel like they're going to see the
person walking into the room that
somehow they have that feeling.
And so they are slate between facing it
and then setting it aside.
And you get this kind of oscillation
during acute grief and gradually,
um,
the,
you find some way,
and people do this differently to but to
think about the fact,
okay,
they're gone and that it's natural for
people to die.
And you know,
you come to terms with that emotionally
as well as kind of cognitively or in
your thoughts.
So you have two basic forms of grief and
you have this oscillating trajectory
that eventually leads to a place where,
where it's in the background and where
you just kind of revisit it from time to
time in your life.
Huh?